on entend les gens parlaient eux ils
font partie
qui décroche de l'autre côté touche pas
ça
je veux juste voir si les marches et 10
passes et boutons craint de faire pendre
il ajouté
l'espace
allo alors je m'appelle kessy cook
je suis prisonnier à vos artistes alger
été enlevé avec deux autres filles
bonjour je m'appelle hedwig j'ai
déchaussé trop jeune
elle va arriver dans pas longtemps qui
va arriver dans pas l'odeur qui est
quelqu'un va venir pour vous et vous
allez détester ça les filles vous faites
du bruit en dormant petit nous qui sait
je peux pas j'ai pas le droit
elle a fait des choses horribles à des
gens elle va aussi vous faire des choses
horribles combien as-tu elle n'entre pas
botola vous n'avez rien à craindre je
vais lui parler il écoute quand cela
vient de moi
il est perturbé il sait pourquoi vous
êtes ici il lui est interdit de vous
toucher
il le sait
en ce moment avec qui est cette
conversation docteur fletcher jeu super
u
cela ne ressemble pas à barrer baril est
un leader extraverti suis comme ça je
vais faire une supposition de
clinicienne basé sur la description
précise et exhaustive des 23 identité
que le corps de kevin abrite sa gelée a
pris par baril je dirais que je
m'adresse à dennis je me réjouis que
nous puissions enfin faire connaissance
je les vis n'est parce que vous avez
rectifié deux fois la position de la
coupelle du chocolat depuis que vous
êtes ici je constate que vous avez des
toques cette intelligente je suis pas de
nice cela fait pas mal de temps
maintenant que patricia et vous avait
été banni de la lumière
la principale raison de ce bannissement
été vos croyances le ciel de nuit sont
des personnes instables je ne suis pas
de nice maintenant vous avez le contrôle
tous les deux mois je vous plais le suis
pas
[Musique]
excusez moi monsieur je crois que vous
vous trompez de voitures plusieurs mails
deux jours de suite pour avoir un rendez
vous dites moi ce qui vous arrive
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu un cas semblable 23
identité vivent dans le corps de kevin
dites moi ce qui s'est passé est une
fleur sur les oreillers il ya une fleur
dans la salle de bain on doit avoir de
l'importance c'est qui ça elle peut-être
nous aider
ne vous inquiétez pas il sait pourquoi
vous êtes ici il lui est interdit de
toucher à vous il le sait je m'appelle
est bing j'ai des chaussettes rouges
rendu à quel âge
le cerveau humain est l'objet le plus
complexe de l'univers la seule façon de
tirer du sist qu'ils décident de nous
laisser sortir c'est toi la plus maline
tu pourrais nous était hedrick ok ya une
fenêtre dans ma chambre tu fais bien de
la montrer regarde là à les fermer
là elle est ouverte a cru que c'était
une vraie fenêtre et que tu pourrais tu
en avais
un individu a personnalités multiples
peut modifier sa physiologie par la
force de la pensée
quelqu'un va venir vous chercher
que se passera-t-il quand il libérera
tout le potentiel de son cerveau il n'y
a pas de limite à ce qu'il peut devenir
cette nuit est sacrée vous allez être en
présence de quelque chose de plus grand
tube le monde va comprendre maintenant
la bête existe
elle a fait des choses horribles à des
gens elle va vous faire aussi des choses
horribles
[Musique]